You'll have,
and I see your Schwartz is his biggest
mind.
That must be Lord far.
Quads castle.
That's the place.
Do you think maybe he's compensating for
something?
Oh my God.
Oh,
oh God.
I just.
I remembered there's just this teeny
tiny thing.
No,
no,
no.
Sexual comedy is one of the most
universal and popular genres of comedy
in cinema pds.
Sorry,
Tourette's.
Notice.
She has it too.
It's something pretty much every adult
can relate to and has the potential for
big laughs while often used for comedic
effect.
I want to look at how sexual imagery,
specifically phallic symbols can be used
to achieve dramatic effects.
Filmmakers can use phallic symbols to
tremendously contribute to the visual
storytelling of a film.
Penis shapes are everywhere and while
not always acknowledged,
there's no doubt that skyscrapers,
he went to a funny
match go up guns
or even a pipe,
so at a certain point he brings out this
pipe and what pipe does he bring out?
It brings out the Sherlock Holmes pipe
one.
You can say it's a sexual thing because
my life is bigger than yours.
All right,
and can be treated as phallic symbols.
Psychologist Sigmund Freud is famous for
theorizing that we noticed these objects
are phallic on a subconscious level in a
similar way of thinking.
Filmmakers use phallic symbols in place
of actual sex to get a subconscious
emotional reaction from the viewer.
The simplest and most noticeable use of
a phallic symbol is to imply sex in
film.
Sexist more often imply been actually
shown,
especially with strict censorship during
the golden age of cinema.
That band showing sex on screen,
so instead of actual sex,
we see sex represented in a phallic
take me to work going
black.
The object can be anything from a
bedpost in the birth of a nation,
a train entering a tunnel in north by
northwest,
a man pumping gas into a woman's car and
written on the window or a gun,
and Bonnie and Clyde
drove phallic symbol.
We see there's some kind of sexual
relationship or desired sexual
relationship between the two characters.
Another common form of Phallic symbol is
to show masculinity.
A gun is a powerful phallic symbol that
indicates the masculinity of a
character.
A big gun means your manly and the
heroes and classic action movie seemed
to always have ridiculously sized
weapons.
If a girl has a big gun,
we know she's reversing gender roles and
taking on masculine qualities.
Small guns,
on the other hand,
are a sign of weakness or vulnerability.
That's what I'm talking about.
Noisy cricket.
Okay.
No,
no.
Come on man.
You get a series.
We atomize.
I get a little midget cricket.
The gun sights issue even gets addressed
in the James Bond Film.
Dr. No as a spy bond has to conceal a
small gun,
but the film makes it clear that it's
still mainly with the delivery,
like a brick through a plate glass
window.
Another example is written on the wind.
When Kyle Threatens Mitch with a pistol,
the small size of the gun further
reinforces the idea that kyle is
cowardly week and feminine.
He doesn't appear threatening with such
a small weapon.
This parallels nicely with the fact that
Kyle's impotent and so he's missing a
major aspect of being a man.
Phallic symbols can also be used to
convey domination and control.
We see this symbolism hyperbolically in
a clockwork orange,
a clockwork orange conveys the idea that
if you can expose someone sexually,
you have complete and utter domination
over them.
So when Alex,
where's the Phallic Mask and beats the
couple with a phallic stick or uses a
phallic statue to toy with an old lady,
he's asserting his complete control over
them.
It shows that to physically dominate
someone is to also sexually dominated
someone.
Sex and violence go hand in hand.
Phallic symbols.
Eight,
the visual storytelling of the film
because they help show Alex go from
dominating to being dominated.
He goes from overpowering everyone to
literally being squished by authority.
Alien uses phallic symbols to convey
fear.
The writer of the film intentionally
made alien contain rape imagery to make
the film more terrifying.
One thing that people are all disturbed
about if sex,
everybody is always all in a not about
sex.
I said,
that's how I'm going to attack the
audience.
I'm going to attack them sexually and
I'm not going to go after the women in
the audience.
I'm going to attack the men and I'm
going to put in every image.
I can think of that.
I know will make them in the audience,
cross their legs,
homosexual,
rl,
right,
birth the thing,
laser tags down your throat,
the whole number,
the parallels between the alien attacks
in real life rape,
make the alien attacks more horrific,
getting raped as a scary thing,
and the writers use the horrors of rape
to make the alien a scarier villain.
The design of the alien is very phallic
in the set pieces look equally as valid
and vaginal.
This design was done very intentionally
by set designer hr Geiger kegers work
with sexual,
and that's the most mild thing you can
say about it.
It's the opening of the alien ship.
Looks like two giant Vaginas on a 60
foot and set.
We built that set.
It wasn't a miniature show,
my God from direct mouth inside alien to
the face hugger laying eggs orally to
the phallic chest.
Buster,
the whole alien is Phallic.
You're looking at this sort of gray
penis.
Can I say that,
but instead of using phallic symbols to
show manliness or domination,
alien uses phallic symbols to show us
being sexually dominated by the alien.
The Phallic symbols evoke terror by
making the human sexual victims to the
alien.
The Phallic symbols add to visual
storytelling in the film by making the
alien attacks visually and emotionally
similar to sexual assault.
Phallic symbols work even when they're
subtle.
A film like the social network is a
perfect opportunity to use phallic
symbols because the whole film revolves
around the fight for power,
sex,
and high social status.
The winklevoss twins take mark
Zuckerberg to their final clubhouse as a
way to show off their high status and
power in order to help convince mark to
work for them.
They offer him a sandwich to further
show off their luxuries and the way it's
presented to them is just so oddly
family
and then he holds it like this,
and then after mark questions,
their idea and internally thinks of a
better one,
he holds the sandwich like this request,
myspace or friendster.
Is it just a coincidence?
Maybe,
but maybe not.
There's definitely a point where the
analysis of Phallic symbols becomes
overkill.
Sigmund Freud once said,
sometimes a cigar is just a cigar.
Not everything that looks valic has some
sexual meaning,
but when used intentionally,
a phallic symbol can be a powerful
visual that adds meaning to what's
happening on screen.
So the next time you watch a film with
your friends and notice a phallic
symbol,
feel free to point it out.
Just don't be a huge dick about it.
You don't have to be a history major or
a political scientist to see the bigger
dick foreign policy theory.
It sounds like this,
what they have bigger dicks
bob
course,
the bombs and the rockets and the
bullets are all shaped like Dick.
It's a subconscious need to project the
penis into other people's affairs.
It's called fucking
thanks for watching.